foreign
[Music]
I love sunshine I love butterflies but
more than anything I love God hey
shut the [__] up [__] piece of [__]
that's Doug the best owner in the world
we're playing this game called Fetch and
[__] [__] he drops me off really far
away and drives home without me when I
bring the ball back he says [__] that's
how I know I won the game
hey honey you ever been with an Afghan
before I don't think so but thank you
thank you for me kid he left your ass oh
that can't be right you are officially
astray that would mean
tuck doesn't love me poor little guy I
should probably talk to him I am a
therapy dog Fred you could learn how
beautifully conceived when you're off
the lead this beer is making me dizzy
he's about to get real Dizzy up in this
[__] I'm having a great time this
[__] right here
little [__] ass friend with the
[__] home perm and [__] what
did you just say I really hate for this
to get violence you were straight you
can do anything you want I'm going back
to Doug's what the [__] man he needs to
pay for what he did with the only thing
he truly loves I'm gonna bite his dick
off oh wait did he just say yeah I'm
still a little drunk but I said I'm
gonna bite his dick off oh we gon [__]
[__] up
big day today you've ever humped
anything before I wouldn't say I've
humped or saved there you go red I'm
doing good tell him you're his daddy hey
gnome I'm your father it's good to
finally meet you right even under these
strange circumstances
but completely lost and my little puppy
paw pads are really hurting right now so
how exactly could this get worse
oh my God holy [__]
oh
[__] guys we've got a dick to Ripper
what are those kind of looks like food
oh [__] uh give me a second you look
different [__] you look different too
how so is it my human hands
[Music]
oh